any brother any comments
here yes
brother Salam alikum uh after uh I
watched the program uh I feel that bad
she made it clear that she did not want
Dr nyak to clear his viewpoints and she
purposely she asked the controversial
question of Usama bin ladin and when Dr
nyak he tried to clear that by saying
that uh we can't base our opinion on the
news of BBC and CNN so she cut him down
and she disagreed with him whereas on
the other side when Karen johar he
narrated an incident which inspired him
to make the movie My Name Is Khan and he
said that he saw a bunch of people a
bunch of educated people some of them
were even passed out from Oxford
University and he said that they were
saying bad things about Islam and kareno
said that how can someone go against the
Muslim Community just basing their
opinions on some information which the
New York Times gives or the media or the
news at that time barad she agreed with
Karen Jor so over here we see the double
standards of baradat one side she
disagreed with Dr Nik and the other side
she agreed the Viewpoint of Karan Johor
so I being a fan of Dr Nik I feel very
offended that uh Dr Nik did not get a
chance to clear his viewpoints and uh I
really look forward that Dr n comments
on this uh issue yeah inshallah we'll
ask Dr Zak but before that we' put the
floor open for more comments from our
audience any brother yes
brother uh can we have your name you
know in profession before you put
forward your
question uh my name is Mosin Khan and uh
I'm a freelancer when I got to know that
Dr naak had been to We the People show
with baradat and Shah ruk Khan I just
bombarded it on the internet like
anything I had a SMS group Facebook fan
pages and all and I bombarded it like
anything I know a guy from Pakistan his
name is fared Ahmed he told me that are
you sure Dr n is going to come on NDTV
because I've sent lacks of messages on
Pakistan so that people will be watching
it so I said yeah this is why I have got
to know and there is shity but after
watching this program it was like oh my
God why Dr Zak even accepted it like you
know in full 1 hour program just for 2 3
minutes though alhamdulillah Dr zakin PA
up point and did pass on the message
like the last message was given the
Muslim should know how to reply in the
media alhamdulillah he made a point and
I feel like people will be keep hunting
him like on internet on YouTube here and
there alhamdulillah I feel Allah is the
best planner and inshah it will
definitely benefit us and J Allah for
this program inshah I hope this will
clear many questions which arise on the
lcks and millions of people around the
world jaak brother any last comment here
before I put forward some questions to
Dr Zakir yes brother
asalam alaikum my name is Aman I saw the
entire program from a to zed and the
whole program was a total mess I feel
baradat was not able to handle it well
and according to me the MTS vessel made
the most noise especially that person
what's his name is Kabir unknown
person never heard of him who and under
what Authority he came to speak on Islam
thank you
jazak Brothers for your kind comments uh
now I think
we have some comments and responses from
Dr zaker uh to some of the queries
raised here as well as some of the
questions you know so many hundreds and
hundreds of questions we've received uh
what I thought would be the right format
is to put Club some of the questions on
the same theme and the on the same uh
context together five or six questions
and I'm sure Dr Zakir was the kind of
memory as he'll remember all of them and
try to do justice to them I read out
some of the questions you know we
received uh either on the website
sometimes on the NDTV website some on
the Facebook and some by email received
the irf itself harun asan he asked Dr
Zakir I'm very much disappointed you
should not have attended such a
show Sayad us Ahmed resi he says I
really like a sentence for Dr Zakir in
that program irrespective of what
happened he says there is nothing like
moderate Muslim or full Muslim it is
just practicing or not practicing
Muslims but I still think Dr NY
shouldn't have attended
this we have brother abrar Khan who says
assalamu alaykum I didn't understand why
the hell m Mr Nik visited the show
conducted by few I can't say that word
Dash holes where he was not allowed to
speak and where image of Islam has been
liberalized and put with wrong picture
does a person with full of knowledge
should attend that kind of programs or
functions then there is abrar Khan he
says wasam I too personally respect Mr
Nike a lot and and I praise him all the
time but what he done was a very
embarrassing
decision and uh lastly I put forward
this question of brother fayaz V he says
I also agree Dr Zakir shouldn't have
dialogue with Bara she knows nothing of
economy religion statesmanship culture I
was upset to see some people have just
superficial knowledge of Islam and world
and they just say rubbish like srk and
Sali it was partly public it stunt for
my name is Khan ubed Muhammad I'm
wondering how Dr Zakir Nik sir accepted
invitation for this show I request sir
not to attend such programs so we
directly throw all these suggestions
questions the perspective of the many
audiences who look up to Dr Zakir
himself I think he is the best person to
answer them not we all so let's get over
to Dr Zakir himself yes Dr zaker feel
free to comment on whatever has been
spoken till now this question why did I
attend this talk show we the people on
any TV this has been asked to me a few
hundred times in the past two weeks
personally on email on Telephone from
people in Bombay from people in
different parts of India from people in
different parts of the
world and many people told me those who
know me personally that after the show
you had with Faruk shik after see the
deceit how did you attend this show and
after the show that I attended with
Faruk shik on M though I don't blame him
I blame the producer I always had a
condition as I mentioned earlier I
received a few hundred invitations in
the past couple of years a few hundred
maybe a thousand from different channels
in India asking me to attend TV talk
shows panel discussions chat shows and I
put the condition that it should either
be live
and unedited or let us have our own
camera crew of at least six to seven
cameras to shoot the talk show so that
if you edit something we'll show it live
on our Channel and when the first time I
received the invitation for the talk
show on NV with the
people I wasn't there in the country so
it was refused when they again
approached then I put the condition that
we want to have our cameras on The Talk
show and it was agreed by the
coordinator who was coordinating and
calling me for the show so my manager
mbul he said if you allow us to have our
cameras on the talk show then Dr Nike
will come and he said that won't be a
problem he readily agreed so I said no
problem if they do some editing then
surely we can add the unedited version
on the other channels so that was the
reason that I decided to attend this
talk show but un unfortunately just one
day before the talk show the coordinator
told me that brother Zakir you know we
having the program in Taj lands and when
I spoke to him personally and the place
is so small we already having our six
cameras and you being a man of media you
know how difficult it to accommodate
more cameras I knew this is just an
excuse I'm a man of media in the Taj
land I can accommodate more than 12
cameras this place is smaller than Taj
lands and here we have nine cameras Taj
lands five star hotel is multiple time
bigger than this when here we can have
nine cameras why can't we have it there
so I knew it was just an excuse but then
asked a condition that will you give me
an unedited version of the complete show
on a digital beta cam format or DV cam
whichever shooting on I'm not aware
whether the anytv shoots on digital beta
cam or DV cam but we normally shoot only
on digital beta cam or something better
so he told me yes Dr AR that I can do
I'll give you an unedited version
immediately after the show which is of
broadcast quality and with this
condition I attended the show but alas
when I inquired with other people when
the show got over and when we asked for
the United version they said okay we'll
give it to you very shortly you know
maybe after telecast he said fine that's
fine after telecast so that we don't
utilize the material then after the show
was telecast when my manager inquired
for the copy they gave after several
days that also on DVD and it wasn't an
unedited version it was the same edited
version was shown on the television what
is the use of giving that we already
have recorded that and initially when I
attended the program people told me that
bar you know
she's very
challenging she's outspoken and she has
a ways in trying to make a person say
what she wants to say but I said no
problem since the show will be uned with
me there not a problem and with that
intention I went for the show and though
I know that she did give me less time
initially the coordinator asked me to
come on the show asked how many people
are there so he told me that shuk Khan
Karan johar Alik padam and he said maana
mad from Kerala so I said molana mad
from Kerala I don't know any M mad from
Kerala I said I want to know the full
name and he said no no I'm sorry it is M
mm mad from Delhi oh I know the person
mallah he's a close friend of mine so I
said fine since there four panelists and
I'm the fifth one seeing the situation
the more the number of panelists the
less chance a person gets even if it's
divided but unfortunately when I went on
the show I saw there were additional
three besides the four he mentioned
there was najib Jang I met him for the
first time the vice Chancellor of jam
Mill from Delhi and Kabir who I was told
was a f producer or film director I'm
not sure and so halik Khan so three
additional panelist so it became eight
but but when I went on the show I
realized that even the time that is
given to me if you feel divided would be
less but though the
show according to me I was given less
time
but in spite of the other things I said
fine at least I made a few points and
even if these are
shown there will not be a problem but
when I saw the show one week later on I
was
shocked I was utterly shocked that my
answers were edited and especially those
answers which are critical and would put
me on the wrong
side that's the time I said that the
intention of the producer of the program
and the intention of the moderator has
to be verified because the answer that I
gave on AMA bad most of the people who
see me on the television they know it
very well I don't want to repeat the
answer but when I
mentioned that irrespective Whoever has
done the 911 attack whether it's George
Bush or s ladin whether Muslim or
non-muslim whoever has done it should be
condemned that part was edited so when
you edit a major portion of it the ACT
has to be condemned if you don't know
the person you cannot blame a person
without proof so I condemn the ACT irres
to whoever did it when that part is
edited it shows as though I'm a
supporter
ofad I'm neither a supporter neither I'm
against him because I don't know and as
brother rightly said when I'm telling I
don't know because I cannot base my view
on BBC and CNN B says come on Dr Z as
I'm telling a lie same thing Kar johar
says that you got angry at about six
non-muslims three of them who are
investment bankers two of them Oxford
University graduates when they speak
against Muslims and he said how can you
blame the whole Community just on news
got on New York Times and News Channel
she says y so this shows the double
standards and rightly brother said that
when she's agreeing with Karan says you
cannot base your views on New York Times
and news channels and when I say I
cannot base my views of AMA bin ladin
based on BBC and CNN she immediately
interjects and she's cutting me down so
this shows the intention that the
moderator was Bast she was not truthful
so that's the reason the whole show what
I thought at I make my point I did not
expect her to be so unjust and the
producer that they cut my answers and
they did not do it once they did it
several times one when I gave when na J
when he said something and I said that
counseling is allowed and I said that if
a person doesn't have drug and I tell
him don't have drug then the person will
agree with me this part they
should but when I said later on that I
being a doctor if I am a doctor and I
give advice to a patient because that
person considers me to be an expert in
the field of medicine then people agree
with me when someone considers me to
have knowledge on Quran but when I give
the advice on Quran they don't follow so
this portion of doctor's analogy was
edited so why do they edit so this shows
that to attend a talk show you may be an
expert but if the intentions of the
moderator and the producer are not right
even the best person to appear on a talk
show he can be showed on the other side
he can be showed in the negative way
because as I said you can edit you can
cut therefore the best is to go on a
live talk show which is AED without
editing or you have a moderator and a
producer of the show who are not Bast
and truthful and honest like example the
NV interview done byar Gupta I really
admire the person he may have disagreed
with some of my views but he was honest
so looking back at it because we put the
conditions I went on the show and when I
put this conditions to many other
channels
they refuse saying we will not allow but
NTV at least this show we the people I
think they went a step further by saying
we agree and one day before disagreeing
and promising us to give an unar version
which they have not given so I feel the
intention what I thought I trust in any
TV as a whole I don't blame them because
the earlier program they had of mine was
fantastic but this maybe the producer is
different and the moderator is different
they aren't the same as Shar Gupta so
but look looking back again when I saw
the show I was initially very disgusted
that I should not have gone on the show
later I told my staff at least take my
portion and let me see how much I've
spoken so one of my staff he took out
all the portion and it was 6 and 1 half
minutes 6 and 1 half minutes I was happy
but then I realized in that 6 and 1/2
minutes 2 and 1 half to 3 minutes was
spoken
by I spoke for only 207
seconds I did a
calculation coming to Less Than 3 and a
half
minutes
and this is what I
felt but when I saw the portion of my
portion only even if they've edited it
yet as Allah says in the Quran in Sur is
chapter 17 vers number
81 when in falsehood falsehood perishes
for falsehood is bias nature bound to
perish when I saw the emails and I read
the emails that came on comments on NDTV
my Muslim and non-muslims I was
shocked believe me I was shocked out of
the emails I read
two3 were either telling the doctor Z
did not get enough time either they're
speaking
against that means on the positive side
that they could see through maybe
because they know my answers or they
aware of my
speeches so I was happy that two3 of
them the emails that I read because
maybe theyve seen these people maybe my
fans or whatever it is or they have seen
me the non-muslim the Muslims that the
reason they did not appreciate the way
it was conducted or of the balance mon
thir half of them were neutral half of
them were critical saying that see Zak
here you know he didn't get a chance so
they were happy about it but overall I
feel even what they have done and as IM
rightly said the message the major point
for put across what's the definition of
a
Muslim nothing like moderate Muslim
either it practicing partially
practicing or non-practicing Muslim so
these points about the various things
that are spoken to the media at least I
made a point and those who were
intelligent got it so alhamdulillah
irrespective what happened I feel what
happens happens for good and Allah
subhana taala is the best to make his
message spread
jazak Dr Zakir for your elucidative
comments on what all we received by
email and the comments from our brothers
here we continue on with this discussion
on TV talk shows and
Analysis I present some more of the
emails and website comments we have
received there's one brother zahed Malik
he says NDTV wasted precious time of Dr
Zakir there is wakas shik Muhammad who
says Dr Zakir n had too much patience I
would have said directly to the host
that you did not give me enough time to
speak in front of everyone as far as
that comment is concerned that you did
not give me enough time to speak has
been told to be many many of my friends
said that Dr n you should have said on
the show that please don't edit this you
on the show and you have not given me
enough time but maybe that would have
been edited it too that's correct so
that's what I said that if I would have
said that that means I'm falling in the
Trap because I know the media so that
person being a no wise many of my
friends told me you should have openly
said in the show that don't edit this
portion and give me enough time so what
they would have done they have showed
that portion that don't edit this
portion and give me enough time and yet
edited the other portion so have looked
that they are very
honest they even showing that portion
where I mentioned don't edit though
editing other parts and even showing
that portion give me enough time so what
we realize that me being a man of the
media I do not fall into the Trap I
didn't make that comment but these
people may not be knowing how editing
can be done in the postproduction that
the reason I do appreciate the comment
but I being a man of the media I avoid
falling into the TR with the lead we
continue with the comments the next
brother brother Muhammad ibal says why
don't you call only Zakir n by to know
about Islam he will let you know
everything whatever you all want
this is my challenge inshallah he'll
answer all your questions with authentic
sources so let's see what NDTV do next
there sister Taha SAR who says you
people just wasted Dr Zakir nik's
precious
time I think a similar kind of comments
we receiv received from many of the
websites and emails then Adil a says
that was expected filmmakers government
employed clergies but were trying to
explain their own Islam while as Dr Nik
was totally sidelined that was quite
clearly a drama which was manipulated
professionally by
baradat then we have Abdullah baa who
says brother Zakir is a wise person that
he attended and he was smiling all the
time may Allah protect him and give hiah
to others
aen we have
brother musfik Sultan he says this
program was a campaign against modesty
and a campaign for
immodesty and Rebellion against religion
a useless program they bought Dr Nike to
increase their viewership and they all
joined to pounce on him Sayad Ahmed says
don't judge on what you
see how do you know that she hardly
knows anything we should not speak about
others when we were not sure that what
Dr Nik said yesterday so who says he's a
man of wisdom and knowledge Dr Zakir Nik
is the most knowledgeable scholar of
this era his personality and knowledge
about Islam and other religions is so
concrete and authentic that everyone is
compelled to listen to him and have put
so many people around the globe on
mustakim and we have candid comments
from Brother Adel aim he says hi Bara I
was a fan of you but you let me down you
were biased were Dr Zakir n and molana
mad called just for publicity of the
show they were not given a chance to
speak you want to know about Islam and
Muslims from people who are not experts
in Islam if you think that Shah ruk Khan
and so Ali Khan represent Muslims of
India then I must insist you are wrong I
would reiterate the
Hadith Asim
mentioned
Salma
narr that rasool sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that time will also come
upon the people when the truthful will
be condemned as liars and the Liars will
be regarded as
truthful people with dishonest
occupations will be regarded as upright
people while upright people will be
condemned as
criminals people will come forth
uncalled to give evidence for a fee and
people will take Oaths
false without it being called for one
suggestion try to know about Islam from
Quran and
experts we have sister shama go saying
your program we the people was useless
not worth watching Dr Zakir Nik was not
given any chance to speak and was
deliberately
interrupted Bara was really not
interested in knowing about the Muslim
identity all she was busy was in cutting
off Dr Zakir nik's comments and not
letting him complete his point of view
all the focus was more given to
srk it was a completely a promotional
platform and event built by NDTV to
promote his film my name is Khan 90% of
the time was given to fools who don't
know what Islam is we have
interpret comments from Sister shumila
sidik who
says the show was totally
unfair Bara didn't give much chance to
Dr zaker to speak it was more for the
publicity of my name is Khan than
knowing about the muslim's identity Bara
interrupted Dr Zakir again and again and
didn't let him clear his points when
shauk has himself said that he doesn't
know much about Islam then it is foolish
to ask him anything about Islam it's
like you are ask a driver about heart
problem even in the end Dr Zakir was not
given chance to make the final statement
Bara skipped Dr Zakir and moved towards
SOA then by themselves raised the issue
of a beard and a cap and then shuk said
that we should not go for how does a
Muslim look like we should go for how
does he feel so if you didn't want to
know that how should Muslim look like
then why did you people raise the issue
of a beard and a cap again a foolish act
it was the waste of the precious time of
Dr Zakir that show was
useless we have another sister RMA M who
says I was truly disappointed from this
discussion having Renown people like Dr
NY and not being able to bring his
points to the audience was disappointing
and when he did speak he was sadly cut
off he's after all a well-learned
scholer but as SAR and SOA and likewise
people were given more than necessary
Spotlight of the whole
talk to the extent that they look like
the show was more based on mnik and such
matter and what the actor thought of
what should be done and what not the
show was a big disaster and all that
they did succeed in was to reconfirm my
belief that how much ever people try to
be open-minded they can never accept
Muslim Muslims with their whole
package whether it be the skull cap and
hijab or just merely verses of the Quran
and yes I agree with Dr Nike there are
either practicing Muslims or just plain
Hypocrites and as far as hijab goes all
I have to say to everyone who's got a
problem back off those were candid
comments from some of our uh websites
especially the NDTV one as well as
Facebook
We Begin this continuing session with
questions from the
audience our brothers collected here to
Dr zaker Nik our brothers have seen
various talk
shows especially the last one with Dr
Zakir appeared
on NDTV we would like you out of your
experiences your practical understanding
if you have any
question as far as understanding what
talk shows are all about this is your
opportunity to ask Dr Zakir feel free
feel open do ask we have Dr zaker to
answer your questions yes
Brothers yes
brother I would like to ask Zakir B
whether these news channels aren't for
trps and for money and uh they want the
populist opinion which will attract more
audiences but as a not only the news
channels most of the channels they
mainly see they get more trp and having
this view of having more trp is not
wrong but showing a wrong view to have
more trp that is wrong to see to it that
you get more viewership on your channel
is a good intention but to show a wrong
impression to increase your viewership
that is wrong so most of them because as
you rightly said that most of the
channels are commercial channels and the
intention is to start a channel is to
earn money so many of time they go
against the truth just to see that the
viewership increases yes any brother yes
brother
asalam before I put forward my question
I would like to make a comment on the
program after watching the program VI
the people I realized as a fan of Dr
zakin n that what a mess it could make
if we ask the opinion of every person
namesake Muslim
about Islam and the Muslims and it has
reaffirmed my faith in the words of the
Glorious Quran where it says if you do
not know ask those who know that's right
coming to my question during the course
of the talk B to a question to the
panelist that most of the Muslims have
become image conscious and they have
given more concentration on wearing a
skull cap sporting a beard and the
Muslim woman wearing the hijab
and as usual as bad was doing she
avoided your comments on this and she
put forward to the other panelist that
was najib Jang brother najib Jang said
that most of the Muslims who wear the
skull caps sported a beard and wear the
nikab are less than a perc which I
strongly disagree with I would like to
have an enlightened answer by Dr Zaki n
on the same because I consider him to be
an expert on Islam and comparative
religion as far as the commment made by
by najib Jang that less than 1% of the
Muslims in India we this identity 0
mentioned by that the men were a skull
cap and a beard and women the bka he
said less than
1% in India we this identity and he also
said that in my University he's the vice
Chan of jamilia he said that we have
20,000 students girls and boys and Dr up
in skull cap or
less than 1% from them we this I haven't
mean to Jia I don't know the percentage
but surely as far as the Indian Muslims
are concerned I totally disagree with
him in my humble opinion not that I've
research but looking people around
traveling throughout India I feel those
people who wear a beard amongst the
non-muslim will be more than 1% Leever
said Muslims among the non-muslims in
India and throughout the world will be
more than
said Muslims Muslims I would say easily
somewhere close to 25 to 30% minimum I
feel minimum from the Indian Muslims 25
30% of the men would be keeping a beard
as far as the skull cap is concerned
maybe about maybe close to 15 to 20%
wearing a skull cap both put together
would surely be more than 10% both put
together both put together wearing
together would be minimum 10% and either
of it either a beard or a skull cap
would be be close to 35 to 40% so I
totally disagree with najib Jang on
analysis and he further said that it's
only in India we got this from the
Hindus when we pray we wear a cap this I
agree this thing that covering the head
while prayer is more common in India but
it's not coming from the Hindus covering
that is not compulsory but it's the sun
of the prophet and there are many Hadith
is mentioned s bukari volume number
seven in the book of dress in chapter
number 16 where the Prophet covered his
head it's also mentioned in s bukari
volume number seven Hadith number 5807
where the Prophet covered his head and
there are various other it's a Sunnah
there's no Hadith showing that ever
Prophet went outside with his head
uncovered though it's not a f in Islam
it's a Sunnah so it is a part of the
Muslim entity and same with the beard
what I fail to realize that I don't know
about jamilia but I'm sure though I have
not been to jam Mia even there the
students inshallah if they are Muslims
would surely be more than 10% would
either be having a cap or a beard or
both majority students I think are
non-muslims in Jam no but he said muslim
when we're talking about Muslims the
most students are non-muslims therefore
I'm saying among the Muslim Students
among the Muslim Students I said I don't
know what the percentage is I haven't
Jia and to put the point across even
himself put
so when you're asking I say that at
least 35% to 40% of either one of them
and if you call him whatever type of
Muslim he is he says he a Muslim so he
has a beard why he has it I don't know
but he has a beard any further comments
questions from the brother yes
brother myself Mohammad n my question is
that on that show there was a question
asked to Malana mad
what about W mataram and the answer
given by him was not satisfied what is
your opinion about W mataram and just
explain us the translation of v
matam as far as the answer given by
molana m on V matam it was correct it
was a short answer he had to give he
said that to force anyone to say V
mataram is wrong it is his opinion so
the answer was right though because it
was you know in short it may not be the
complete answer which he may be having a
longer version being a talk show he gave
a short version so what he said that you
know you cannot force anyone to say
anything because India is a free country
So based on that I agree on that part as
far as the view on vand mataram V
mataram means I bow down to the
motherland one day bow down mam to my
motherland based on this saying that I
bow down to my motherland leave aside
what Islam says even according to Hindu
scriptures what we believe
that in the Hindu scripture if you read
it's clearly mentioned in the Hindu
scripture inar upanishad chapter number
four verse number
19 pratima in Sanskrit means an image a
photograph a picture a painting a
portrait a sculpture an idol almighty
God has got no pratima has got no image
has got no picture has got no portrait
has got no painting has got no statue
has got no Idol has got no sculpture So
based on this almighty God can't have an
image according to scripture same is
repeated in chapter number 3 verse
number
three of that God there is no image So
based on this in Hinduism also making an
image of God is wrong so saying that
this mother land is like your God and
you bow down is wrong even according to
Hindu scriptures and in Islam it's very
clear that we can bow down to no one but
our cre Allah subh tala as far as our
country is concerned we as Muslims we
love the country we respect the country
but we don't bow down to the country not
only in India we cannot even bow down in
Pakistan to that country we cannot bow
down in Saudi Arabia also so it's not
only to India if a Muslim is living in
Saudi Arabia and he's a Saudi national
he cannot bow down to Saudi Arabia a
Pakistan cannot bow down to Pakistan so
it's not only to India because we bow
down only to our God our creator we
cannot bow down even to our own mother
leave aside motherland the woman who
gave us birth who's our mother
we cannot bow down to our own mother so
where is the question of bowing down to
the motherland we love the country we
respect the country our country has
given us many opportunities but we
cannot equate our country neither our
own mother to our create Allah So based
on this according to Islam and according
to Hinduism saying that we bow on to our
country and calling our country as good
as God which is mentioned several times
it is totally
wrong the before we ask the next
question to the audience one or two
emails the bahmad Shaban he says yeah
even I think Dr Nik shouldn't have been
a part of the show but Allah knows the
best Allah does best for his umah maybe
something good is there yet to come
related to the show or may even Dr Zakir
n can arrange a session where he can
reply to all the comments and questions
made in this show jaah and we have sh
Ali who says they didn't give him a
chance but in Allah will support him we
are behind you Dr Zakir Nik all the way
this is your chance can put forward
questions to him yes
brother Visa is the program VI the
people Shah ruk Khan emphasize the need
to explain Islam to other people uh in
this context how is it incumbent on
every Muslim to spread the message of
Islam and how Shah ruk Khan as far as
his question is concerned he said it's
required for the Muslims to explain
Islam to others and I agree with that
it's compulsory for every Muslim to
convey The Message of Islam it is f it's
mentioned several places of the Quran
including Surah Al Imran chapter number
three verse number 110 where it's
mentioned in the
Quran are the best of people evolve for
mankind the Muslims are called as the
best of people and the reason is given
because we enjoy what is good and forbid
what is
wrong we are called as the best of
people for the whole of humankind
because we enjoy what is good and forbid
what is wrong and we believe in Allah so
the reason almighty God is calling us
the best amongst all the peoples is
because we have to convey the message of
Truth call people towards the truth and
join him to the truth and forbid them
from doing wrong so it's compulsory on
the Muslims and there are several other
verses in the Quran like Sur chapter
number 103 verse number 1 to3 which says
one of the criteria to go to Jenna is to
call people towards the truth
any brother yes brother after the show I
read a comment on Twitter on srk Shah
ruk Khan's Twitter that he said that
post show he had some discussion with
you and he has mentioned that after a
post show I had a discussion with Dr
zakin and it was very enlighting I would
like to know what was that enlighting
session with Shah ruk
Khan oh yes after the show was over I
did chat with shuk Khan for about half
an hour and it was a very good
experience I cannot discuss everything
because many things were personal so
it'll be wrong on me to say in public I
was meeting for the first time it was
the first time I met him personally
though there are some common friends who
are his friends and my
friends but this the first time meeting
him personally and one thing is for sure
that I am happy that I maintained my
policy of not to just rely on the news
but before the show and which
everyone may be aware that it comes in
the media many people many of my friends
have told you know Shah Khan is not a
practicing Muslim and he's not happy to
be a Muslim and he normally gives
comments against Islam and he does this
and that I personally have not heard it
personally on the television I have not
heard because I watch television very
little but because it for comments I
follow the ver of the Quran Quran says
in Surah huat 49 verse number 6 that
whenever you get a message check it up
before you pass on to the third person
the same thing what I use whether the
asking
comment
like I said I don't know same thing even
though you're negative Shan I always
said Allah but what I heard him saying
on the show I'm not talking the chat
after the show what I heard him on the
show I
felt irrespective whether he's
practicing or not but his answers were
far better than most of the Muslims on
the show not counting of course mm mad
he's a close friend of mine m he's a
practicing Muslim but leaving aside him
what answers he gave compared to all the
other Muslims on the show his answers
were more correct and he rightly agreed
saying that you know that though he does
film acting and singing and dancing he
says it is Haram that was good of him
and he says that he has less knowledge
but he also said that for correct
knowledge you should ask the scholars
andas and the mananas so his answers
were far superior than the other people
who are Muslim the talk show and after
for the show one comment I'd like to
make that while discussing on the issue
of Muslim identity he asked me Dr Zak
Nik he said Dr Zak what is your view how
important is it to keep a beard and wear
the cap so giving analogy that it wasn't
a talk show there was
no so I could explain to brother shahruk
Khan more easily and you know without an
interruption so I told him that when you
appear for an examination there are some
questions which have one Mark some
question have 10 marks some question
have 20 marks the Muslim identity
wearing the cap and the beard though
it's not of utmost importance but it is
important it may carry maybe one
Mark you know behaving practically being
honest speaking the truth these points
about Islam the practice may carry 10
marks make G five mons so though keeping
a beard is not the most important you
can miss the one marks and concentrate
on the 10 marks and five marks and 20
marks but if someone wants to score
distinction he will try and even get
this one mark for example when we
appeared for the medical examination we
tried even to get that half mark because
you want to score above 90 so when you
want to score above 90 this is very
important we is important and GAP is
important it's a part of the Sunnah but
if someone doesn't keep a beard you
cannot say that he's not a Muslim you
cannot say he's not a Muslim doesn't
sport a beard or doesn't wear a cap but
oh you have given a very good analogy so
he like the example that it is important
but make car one mark two marks the more
important is is the Amal the other
things about being honest about offering
Salah not doing sh this is of more
importance and as I mentioned even the
talk show that if a person does not keep
a
beard it doesn't come in the 70 major
sins you know there is a scholar by the
name of imabi and he has listed the 70
major sins in Islam first being the shik
then being murder going down the line
but the beard doesn't appear that does
not mean not a sin some Scholars say
that it is a Sunnah
must that's encouraging some Scholars
say that it is f to keep a beard but
whatever it is no one puts it in the
major sin either it's a minor sin or
it's a very important Sunnah so it's not
part of the major hope the answer
that's a good clarification uh maybe
have my brother put forward this
question maybe have your name and
profession please I'm Obed Khan in that
program on NDTV Shah ruk Khan had made a
comment that for a Muslim to look like a
Muslim is not important but to feel like
a Muslim is important I would like to
hear your comment on that to look like a
Muslim I would say is not the most
important but to feel like a Muslim
again feeling may be different as I gave
the earlier
that being honest is more important than
wearing a beard and wearing the cap but
being honest and wearing the cap and the
beard is much better than only being
honest without the
beard but a person who's proud to be a
Muslim would always like to show that
he's a Muslim so if you're proud to be a
Muslim for example when a person passes
medical degree you know he becomes a
doctor when he gets mbbs degree and he
puts a doctor in front of his name why
proud to be a doctor the person who's
proud to be a Muslim he would be proud
to show that he's a Muslim and this is
one of the labels that the Muslim has
that is wearing a beard and wearing a
cap from two comments before I put
forward questions you could ask we have
shahini Ibrahim Hassan sidhi ask in fact
they fear the young zaker sir they need
to show their beliefs is right they
don't think that Islam is most growing
religion without the help of the media
Allah knows best then we have brother
akib who says I'm a practicing Muslim
and I have myself been subjected to
typification and biases many a time but
I feel NDTV and burka are one of the
best things around I agree Zakir Nik
should have been given more time to
speak but it's a shorttime show and all
is not possible shauk has spoken most
wisely and said what Islam actually says
except one or two points which we all
are humans are bound to ear kudos to
NDTV and Barka but yeah KK pami VC Jamia
and SOA spoke their
whims said that what he spoke about
Islam was far better than most of the
other Muslims the show and but natural
The View that the people normally have I
don't know what he is or not but when I
spoke to him after the show and what I
heard the answer in the show and what I
spoke after the show at least what I
experience at least he is not at all
feeling apology to be a
Muslim he is happy to be a Muslim unlike
what people portray so at least my
opinion about him good I did not agree
with the opinion of the others I may be
wrong people may know him better than me
I only met him months but what I heard
live on the talk show and what I had a
discussion after the show at least my
opinion about him is that fine he agrees
he does something wrong but he is proud
to be a Muslim and he would love to
learn more about Islam and that is what
is Islam always believes that not to
just hear what people say but at least
my opinion about him is that not what
people talk about him when I met him
personally you are the different person
yes
brother yeah
welcome shuk Khan again and again but of
late I observed that he's I mean that is
what he says that he is offering Nam
and he plans to go for Hajj inshallah
this year was it I mean I don't know
it's because of interaction with you or
what has made him Allah has given him hi
to pray namas now he's often tweeting
that I'm going for namas and he says
that this year I intend to go for Haj
inshallah tal may Allah give him good
desire I don't know but I do know that
there are common friends between him and
me and he has confessed with me that he
has seen many of my
DVDs and pray to Allah subhana tala that
may give to all of us and may get us cl
to the truth of Islam yes
brother assalam
alayum Zakir B in the show Kabir Khan
made a comment saying that you know if a
mother is wearing hijab and the daughter
adopts this habit of the mother then
this is not free will but if the mother
is not wearing a hijab and the daughter
adopts this habit of wearing a hijab
this is free will do you accept this
definition of Free Will given by Kabir
Khan this definition will be applicable
to some people especially to Kabir Khan
because Kabir Khan he told that he born
in a Muslim family I think maybe that is
the reason he's calling himself a Muslim
maybe he has no free will you know if he
had a free will would have said he's not
a Muslim so this definition does agree
to him that he has not been given a free
will therefore though being born a
Muslim family he calls himself a Muslim
so this definition does apply to him and
it feels that he had no free will to say
he's not a non-muslim if I agree with it
as far as normally what we see that
there are many of the
children who follow the
parents I do agree most of them do it by
blind belief if the father is a Hindu
the children are Hindu If the parents
are Muslim the children are Muslim if
parents are Christian the children are
Christian I do agree to a great extent
that many do blind believe but some of
them question the
parents some of them may do because it's
part of religion some may do because it
is part of culture
but many children they question the
parents and after questioning the
parents they may get convinced what the
parents are doing right and they may
continue so these people now out of free
will they are
continuing what the parents are doing
some people question their parents and
they aren't
convinced and yet they continue doing it
maybe because of peer
pressure maybe because they're afraid
that they cannot go against their
parents but on the other hand some
people who when they question their
parents and they aren't convinced then
they change the ideology and they change
their behavior so these people again out
of free will they're changing so you
can't say for sure that just because the
mother is wearing a hijab the daughter
wears that means no free will and if
mother doesn't wear hijab and then
daughters wear then it's free will this
is totally wrong but even if I agree
with Kabir in the Islam resarch
Foundation there are hundreds or maybe a
thousand girls who are not wearing hijab
and their mothers don't wear hijab but
after coming to a foundation hundreds
and thousands of them within few weeks
or couple of months they have started
wearing
hijab so if his definition that if the
mother doesn't wear in the daughters
there means Free Will so by Free Will in
Bombay itself only coming by a
foundation hundreds and thousands have
started wearing hijab and
furthermore many of the ladies after
watching my programs on the satellite
channel maybe hundreds and thousands of
them have started wearing hijab not in
India throughout the world so this is
his definition of free will then
alhamdulillah when these logical people
when they hear The Logical reason why
hijab should be worn so unfortunately
unfortunately I do agree that the
majority in India they hijab as part of
culture or they were hijab because it's
a religion without knowing the reason
some of them after learning the reason
they continue
but the point to be noted is that if he
convince the youngsters and the ladies
with reason logic and Science Why hijab
is w and the reason of hijab in Islam is
to protect the women then I feel
majority if not all the ladies who are
logical they will wear the hijab that's
the reason there are many non-muslims
accepting Islam throughout the world and
amongst the people accepting Islam
whether India or abroad two3 of them are
women so if hijab subjugates the women
then why are the American women who are
accepting Islam why are the European
women who are accepting Islam they
adoring hijab so hijab is there to
protect the women and everyone has a
right to agree or disagree and based on
that but if you speak logically and if
you explain Islam to them logically I
feel majority of the human will agree
with the points that I mentioned in
Islam Dr Zakir we have two three
comments you know on the web we have Mah
Chi who says I completely agree Dr Nik
deserves to be in a better place and the
lady baradat seem to have no knowledge
of who Dr Nik is I disagree with that
statement Dr Zak disagrees will surely
be KN who I am that is the reason they
had me on the show that is the reason
when she spoke to me the first time in
the show she said that you come on TV
more than me alhamdulillah and when she
asked the third question she said that I
know that you love answering question
from the audience so I disagree with
that statement that she doesn't know me
she knew me but she being an expert
moderator she really
moderated not with honesty but she had a
point of view and as I said earlier that
it depends upon the integrity and the
sincerity of the moderator and the
producer to project the people who are
they on the show I think the sister's
misunderstanding stands corrected we
have Nadia Jamal who says I totally
agree Dr Zakir hardly was given the
chance to speak and brother Zakir in
future should avoid sharing the stage
with jahil Muslims especially like so
Ali Khan and Kabir Khan who don't even
know what Islam is all about and were
arguing that Muslim lady wears hijab
only if she sees her mother wearing it I
have no idea in what kind of a world
they are living new generation are more
practicing than their parents I believe
alhamdulillah and truly I found sha and
Kabir highly disgusting they are not
Muslim so why to call them for
discussions on Muslims and lastly we
have arshad Hussein shik who says lady
Bara is a commercial commodity and so is
srk Kabir SOA and Karan don't these guys
seriously folks little knowledge is a
dangerous thing their opinions don't
make a tiny bit difference towards what
Islam and Muslims stand for there is no
other interpretation of Islam and a
Muslim other than what is said in the
Holy Quran see more Quran and the Hadith
either you are in or you are out of the
circle there is no room for so-called
moderate or liberal Islam or a Muslim
and there is no such word called
extremist or fundamentalist rightly said
by Dr Zakir that either you practice or
you don't simple as that I think Dr
Zakir would like to comment something on
that the person are G right analogy
maybe what I'm just putting across is
straightforward comments you know of the
people some may be right some may not be
right but that is their opinion I say
you either say he's a Muslim or a Pudo
Muslim Muslim or sudo Muslim or you can
say who is a practicing Muslim partially
practicing Muslim or non-practicing
Muslim so non practic Muslim can be
called a pseudo Muslim right terminology
there's nothing like moderate Muslim no
Muslims if he's a Muslim he's
moderate I mean and you can't say person
is an extremist Muslim and I say I'm an
extremist Muslim I'm extremely kind I'm
extremely merciful I'm extremely loving
I'm extremely just I'm extremely honest
so to be a practicing Muslim you have to
be an extremist you can't say I'm
partially honest when it benefits me I'm
honest when it does not benefit I'm not
honest so these are terminology these
loose terminologies made by people and
how it has evolved so these loose
terminologies used by the media
extremist and fundamentalist these if
you go back into history they were used
for somebody else earlier if you have
heard my talk on terrorism and Jihad Etc
and I've clarified that this word
fundamentalist was first used for the
Christians those who believe that the
message of the Bible is not from God
every word every letter is from God
and now today in the new definition of
Oxford dictionary the fundamentalist
mean a person who strictly aderes to the
ancient teachings of any religion the
new definition is slightly changed that
fundamentally is the person who strictly
aderes to the ancient doctrines of
religion especially Islam so though it
was used in the early part of the 20th
century for the Christians today it's
used for the Muslims so this is how they
keep on changing but really fundamental
the person who follow the fundamentals
so if you have to be a good Muslim
Muslim you have to follow the
fundamentals of Islam if you have to be
a good Hindu you have to follow the
fundamentals of Hinduism if you have to
be a good mathematician you have to
follow the fundamentals of
mathematics brother Zak any further
questions from Brothers here yes brother
we'll just ask then we'll come back on
the
front my name is faran and I'm a student
uh Kabir Khan alleged that the
definition of Islam that you gave was
too narrow so I would like to know your
comments on that like does the
definition of Islam what you said does
it change or it Remains the Same the
brother that Kabir Khan said that
definition of Islam is very narrow I
said Islam means a person who submits
his will to Allah subhana tala so if you
want to know the meaning of a word any
word where do you look look in the
dictionary if you want to know the
meaning of any English word you go to
dictionary you don't just say it off the
CU and if you want to verify whether the
person has said right or WR go to
dictionary so you open any Arabic
dictionary Islam comes from root word
Salam which means peace or Salam which
means peace it's also derived from the
Arabic word s which means to submit your
will to God submit so Islam actually
means peace acquired by submitting a
will to God and anyone who submits the
will to God is called as a Muslim so
this is an Arabic word I don't know how
much does Kabir Khan know about Arabic
so person who does not know Arabic
you're asking the meaning of Arabic word
it is like the person said you asking a
dri about the treatment of medical
disease I don't know how much Arabic
does Kabir Khan know and what right does
he have to comment on Arabic word he
doesn't know so this is how the media
you know person doesn't know Arabic and
asking the meaning of an Arabic word
what we realize that if you want to know
you go to the authentic sources and the
best definition to know about Muslim is
go to the Quran Quran
says that many places about Muslim
Muslim Muslim Muslim mean one a person
who bows to the will of Allah in Sur Al
Imran 3:64 and many other places hope
that yes any further questions
yes uh asalam alikum this is Aman bukari
barad doubted your reply which you had
tried to give about the talibans and how
the American Media they manipulate the
the public and according to her CNN and
BBC are the go for her now the very same
CNN and BBC had said that Iraq has
weapons of mass destruction and this was
being relayed on these channels day
after day week after week and months
after months and in spite of America
invading Iraq it was not able to find
any weapons of mass destruction my
question to baradat is come on baradat
where is your answer to this where are
the weapons of mass destruction your
comments please sir